bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir sur rtl france qu'est ce
qui est fait actuellement au brésil pour
lutter contre l'épidémie
bon en fait pour lutter contre
l'épidémie je pense que chacun prend
l'initiative éventuel éventuellement de
ceux de s'isoler ou bien de ne pas sa
gle opérer je veux dire les initiatives
sont très sont particulières d'accord je
sais c'est chacun c'est chacun qui qui
s'isole et qui prend les mesures de
distance de porte son masque et évite
les réunions et les agglomérations
c'est la décision de chacun il n'y a
aucune mesure au plan national aucune
imposition vieux port de masques par
exemple oui allez l'imposition du port
du masque et il y a beaucoup de
l'entreprise qui fonctionne seulement en
gros mon fils mais les supermarchés les
bars sont ouverts les écoles ont été
fermées pendant très longtemps la même
somme en vacances donc on fait là il
faudra revoir à la rentrée ce match et
voilà la population est sensibilisée
vous dit il en va de l'initiative de
chacun des initiatives personnelles mais
ce que vous sentez qu'il ya une prise de
conscience générale de la situation
sanitaire au brésil écoutez cela dépend
des quartiers cela dépend de la
nécessité de chacun il ya beaucoup de
quartiers où les personnes sont obligées
de sortir d'aller travailler pour gagner
gagner leur pain quotidien si je puis
dire
et puis ceux qui ont les moyens de
rester à la maison ne pas sortir et de
travail en home office fonds prise de
conscience collective
on a comme chez vous les antilles
masquer les anti pacs les lentilles les
anti tau donc à une partie de la
population qui est éclairé ou qui en
fait
est consciente de la du danger et une
loutre il ne l'est pas et au niveau de
l'état on l'a entendu jacques bolson
arrow et il le revendique presque
l'économie qui semble devoir passer
avant la santé oui
écoutez là quand même nous sommes en
fait au brésil on a deux marches un
petit peu à deux vitesses ni à l'état
fédéral
il y aller il ya le gouvernement fédéral
qui donne ses ordres etc
il y a le l'état municipal par exemple
ici je suis à rio de janeiro ou en fait
la vaccination était fixée au 25 janvier
par le préfet qui vient d'être élu
eduardo paes notre vaccin ou à rio ne
sera pas le sinovac
quand vincent parle ce sera le le
astrazeneca parce que nous avons ici la
fondation au stade opow est une
institution très ancienne qui fabrique
des vaccinations et qui va fabriquer
qu'un accord avec oak sort mieux avec le
vaccin avec laboratoire astrazeneca qui
par axe qui va fabriquer et distribuer
le vaccin aux fortes on attend 3
millions de doses à la fin du mois voilà
on entend que j'allais lire humble sonar
haut il ya quelques jours déclarait que
le pays était en faillite
une telle déclaration est ce qu'elle
pourrait permettre de justifier
certaines décisions certaines décisions
sanitaires à venir selon vous quel est
le risque
écoutez moi je ne suis absolument pas
économique ni gêner pas d'informations
sur ce jeu presque je pense que je sais
c'est dans le milieu médical et j'ai
assisté ici à plusieurs campagnes de
vaccination les campagnes de vaccination
sont très bien organisés ici parce
qu'elles sont gratuites
en fait vous pouvez aller dans n'importe
quelle campagne dans quel poste
vaccination ici faire le vaccin contre
la diphtérie le tétanos la fièvre jaune
vous pouvez y aller aujourd'hui ça
marche il ya des fois vaccins ont loupé
l'autre qui manquent
on en quelques jours et après les les
de nouveau disponible en ce qui concerne
bien sûr le vaccin contre le contre le
le coronavirus je pense que je pense que
nous aurons le vaccin je suis assez
optimiste
voilà je pense que parce que nous avons
quand même le la fondation de value cruz
l'institut là si tu t'en as en parle
je pense qu'il ya une je pense qu'il ya
une conscience collective de la
nécessité de ce vaccin et je ne pense
pas que 20 jeux en coûte que coûte
alors mes stylos sucer l'euromed à
arriver au brésil il faut aussi pouvoir
langer t on parle de pénurie qui se
rendent dans le pee wee sache aussi je
ne peux pas vous donner plus
d'information là dessus il ya une
question de réquisition des seringues
je ne sais pas sur noir on en aura
suffisamment pour vacciner trois
millions de personnes en un mois
mais bon ca vaut nettement je n'ai pas
d'information je ne sais pas comment
répondre à votre question
merci en tout cas d'avoir pris le temps
de témoigner sur notre antenne chantal
corcos je rappelle que vous êtes un
médecin généraliste en poste donc au
brésil